right wing media darling and persistent
fast talker ben shapiro has come up with
what is maybe his dumbest take ever and
it has everything to do with voter
suppression
and the bill passed in georgia which has
been the subject of the very same
boycotts
that we talked about earlier which have
led to donald trump announcing
counter boycotts of a bunch of different
organizations and companies
here is ben shapiro saying waiting a
long time to vote
is no more voter suppression than
long lines at disneyland are rider
suppression i'm not kidding this is
really ben shapiro's take
he builds up to the disneyland thing
we'll look at some other parts of the
clip
first jim crow explicitly created a
separate system of law for black
americans and treated them as inferior
there's nothing in the law like that
that is that's not only an overstatement
it's just an outright lie
now what's interesting about this is
that ben argues
because voter suppression laws don't
have anything overtly racist written in
them like they don't mention
black people or whatever because it's
not overt
it can't be racist that's very very
wrong you can for example
target black neighborhoods you can
target
black christians who like to organize
rides to go vote on sunday during early
voting
after leaving church you can target them
by saying no sunday early voting as an
example
just because it's not explicitly written
that this is to target black people
doesn't mean that the impact can't be
racist i'm sure
ben knows that his audience doesn't and
he's playing
down to an audience that is ignorant
quite frankly
let's continue but says jamelle hill all
of corporate america should resonate to
the lie
the law imposes new voter identification
requirements for absentee ballots well
clearly that's racist i mean you mean
you have to show that you are who you
say you are when you vote
absentee if you can explain to me how
that's racist i'm willing to hear it
anyone dealer dealer it limits the use
of ballot drop boxes
oh you mean like ballot drop boxes where
people could just stuff the ballot box
or take ballots out of the ballot box
hmm the scholarship on how voter id
is a racial issue is very extensive it's
a very long list
you just some things to consider
minority voters
are more likely to lack id okay
we know minorities tend to be less
economically well-off in the united
states than whites
so while the voter id itself is free as
right-wingers will often tell you
the documents you often need to get your
voter id
aren't free and if you don't have those
documents you not only have to pay for
them
you have to take time off from work to
get id
less economically advantaged individuals
are less able to take time off
from work to go and get the documents
and then get the id
but we also know that voter id laws are
enforced in a discriminatory manner
there's a very good caltech mit study
which found that when you look at who is
questioned about their id minority
voters
are far more often questioned about id
than white voters so understand that
he's wrong about everything he's saying
then ben shapiro talks about taking
ballots out of dropboxes
listen uh that's theoretically possible
no ballot box i've ever seen makes that
possible with the dropbox i used when i
voted it's just a simple engineering
issue there's no way to take ballots out
uh you know the the path into it's an
engineering issue
and either ben is ignorant to that or
again
knows his audience will fall for it
let's continue it hands at state
officials more power over local
elections
even before the legislation passed many
voters of color in georgia faced
hours-long queues at the polls by the
way
voter suppression doesn't involve long
lines
any more than long lines with disneyland
are ride suppression
you know what voter suppression is voter
suppression is where you don't get to
vote
now there is the climax of stupidity the
height of ignorance
it's actually hard to know where to
start because there's
so much wrong with that ben's argument
is
if there's a long line for a roller
coaster it's no more
suppression than if there's a long line
to vote
now first of all voting is a right to
constitutional right
people who are at disneyland are in a
privileged position
of choosing to go to entertainment if
they can afford it disneyland is pretty
expensive
disney disneyland also isn't open one
uh one day per year with some extra days
that are being negotiated and argued
about
okay so there's no comparison here
there's no equivalence whatsoever
second when it comes to waiting periods
for owning guns
suddenly it taking a while is
suppression of one's second amendment
right they say people like ben
say awaiting if you have to you have a
constitutional right to a gun
the day you want it you should be able
to get it okay but so
does the same apply to voting no no same
day registration is dangerous
oh and would you apply the same thing to
waiting in long long lines to vote
no no no that's totally different so the
hypocrisy
number three aside from the absurdity of
comparing roller coasters to voting
disneyland isn't trying to make lines
longer
the strategy by the american right is
exactly that make the lines longer
in left-leaning in poorer in non-white
areas
so that those voters may say uh this is
a pain i'm going home
but keep the lines short in the
wealthier
right leaning and wider areas by having
more polling places
and more polling booths and case in
point this isn't just a hypothesis
a study in georgia found that the
average wait time when polls closed
was six minutes in areas that are 90
white and 51 minutes
in areas that are 90 percent non-white
it's already happening it's not oh they
might do this they've been doing it
somehow ben shapiro was able to put
together a segment
that completely lacks logic and
nuance and accuracy like it it almost
takes
effort to put together such a dumb take
and these are the types of arguments
that you and i might hear them and say
nobody would fall for that
trump won in 2016. people fall
for really stupid arguments all the time
we'll take a quick break make sure to
install
the basic attention the brave
bat browser plug-in this is
a way that is free to you to support the
david pakman show
google brave browser plug-in and install
it
a great thing great new way to support
the david pakman show at no cost to you
when you see me sitting here at the
microphone oftentimes i'm wearing a
shirt
by a company called teddy stratford and
i love these shirts so much that i
asked teddy stratford to be a sponsor of
the show
and here's why i like their shirt so
much with other slim fit button-up
shirts
you often get this weird-looking gap
between the buttons where it looks kind
of stretched out but teddy stratford
actually has a patented zipper
that's hidden underneath the buttons
which secures the shirt against your
chest so it doesn't look
stretched and most importantly it just
provides a nicer looking fit overall
and the entire shirt is specially
designed to really
improve the way your upper body looks
when you're wearing it it also has a
special type of collar
that prevents it from drooping down and
spreading open which is another
really great thing about these shirts
all of these things
really do a lot to make a big difference
when you're looking at a shirt
and that's why i like to wear teddy
stratford shirts on the show
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman at checkout